bonjour à tous à merci de nous retrouver
assure public à senna souvenez-vous
c'était en juillet 2012 le sénat tapé du
poing sur la table concernant les bron
le bronzage en cabine mais aussi les
implants ou encore les épilations à la
lumière pulsée dans le cadre d'une
mission d'information sénatoriale qui
s'était mise en place après le scandale
des prothèses mammaires pays p le sénat
avait formulé plusieurs recommandations
nous pouvons d'ailleurs aller jusqu'à
l'interdiction de ces fameuses cabines à
uv alors trois mois plus tard où en
est-on de ses recommandations le sénat
organisé hier soir un débat sur ce thème
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
pour savoir si ces recommandations vont
faire l'objet d'une proposition de loi
bonne science à tous mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle débat sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables et les
interventions à visée esthétique à la
suite de la demande de la mission
commune d'information portant sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables et les
interventions à visée esthétique
la parole est à madame chantal jouanno
présidente de la mission commune
d'information portant sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables et les
interventions à visée esthétique vous
avez la parole ma chère collègue
hop là
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
très heureux de pouvoir débattre dans
cet hémicycle des conclusions du rapport
sur les dispositifs médicaux
implantables et interventions à visée
esthétique un rapport dont je veux
souligner qu'il a été adopté à
l'unanimité des membres de la mission
est totalement soutenu par la commission
des affaires sociales une unanimité
d'ailleurs à l'image des travaux que
nous avons conduits extrêmement
constructif et extrêmement éclairant sur
un enjeu que je finirais devrait plus
tarder ailleurs est un enjeu vraiment de
société mais en fait nous ne voulions
pas de polémique inutile car cette
mission d'information souvenons-nous ans
est née d'un drame humain qui est celui
de la sphère pays paie un drame dont
d'ailleurs nous découvrons chaque jour
l'ampleur croissante puisque vous le
savez les taux de rupture de ces
prothèses mammaires sont très supérieurs
aux estimations initiales
et malgré les cassandre dénonçant le
principe de précaution nous ne pouvons
que saluer la décision du précédent
gouvernement de proposer l'explantation
préventive à toutes les femmes porteuses
de ces prothèses pour autant à
l'occasion des différentes auditions
nous avons bien noté les difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontés les victimes
qui dénoncent des pratiques parfois
abusives de certains chirurgiens
aussi avons nous demandé au gouvernement
une mission igas pour dresser le bilan
de cette crise sanitaire et faire toute
la lumière sur les conditions
d'exploitation et madame la ministre je
souhaiterais avoir quelques éclairages
sur la prise en compte de cette demande
par le gouvernement vous savez cette
mission n'était pas une contre enquête
sur la sphère pays t et nous avons donc
chou voulu que son champ soit
extrêmement élargi nous nous sommes
concentrés sur les dispositifs médicaux
dit implantable parce que jugés les plus
à risque ce qui courent recouvrent un
champ extrêmement large qui va bien
évidemment des prothèses mammaires aux
prothèses de hanche au stand tout
corps au peace maker et nous l'avons
encore plus élargie à l'ensemble des
interventions à visée esthétique qui
vont du travail des esthéticiennes
jusqu'à la chirurgie esthétique parce
que la sphère pays perd en voyant en
effet souvent cette délicate question du
risque acceptable pour des interventions
jugées à visée purement esthétique et de
la place des pouvoirs publics pour
déterminer le niveau de risque
acceptable
je veux d'abord est vraiment insisté sur
l'enjeu de santé publique parce que
parfois on nous a regardés avec un petit
sourire quand nous évoquions cette
mission d'information l'enjeu de santé
publique c'est pour les seuls
dispositifs médicaux entre 160 milles et
800 mille références aujourd'hui
recensés avec un gap avec une
incertitude qui elle même est
extrêmement préoccupante canton nombre
de références et un marché qui serait
selon l'igas de 21 milliards d'euros
chaque année pour l'aspect esthétique il
y a trois cent mille actes de chirurgie
et de médecine esthétique un marché en
très forte progression et un autre
chiffre très intéressant puisque ce
débat va venir dans notre hémicycle 16%
de la population française fréquentent
les cabines à uv 16% de la population
française ces quelques chiffres pour
souligner que nous sommes face à un
problème de société et pas uniquement un
choix individuel de prise de risque donc
un sujet élargie et une approche élargie
avec l'aide de l'équipe des
administrateurs du sénat équipe
remarquable conduite par olivier jacque
il tient à le dire nous avons mené plus
d'une cinquantaine d'auditions une
cinquantaine d'auditions et nous sommes
nous nous sommes rendus aussi bien
auprès des instances européennes
qu'auprès de pays qui font référence
dans le domaine je pense aux états unis
au danemark en suède
nous aurions bien voulu aller en
australie mais nous avons interrogé les
autorités estoniennes par courrier
c'était plus respectueux des finances du
sénat nous avons aussi interrogé les
spécialistes de la santé les
professionnels les autorités sanitaires
mais également
pour avoir vraiment cette vision d'un
enjeu de société
des psychologues des sociologues des
historiens une approche extrêmement
large pour dépasser la proche purement
technique et nous souhaitions au delà
des aspects sanitaires éclairer les
enjeux sociétaux de ce type de débat
parce que ces enjeux ont la place leur
place dans notre hémicycle
et force est de constater que
l'apparence physique constitue
aujourd'hui une norme et pas seulement
une question de bien-être mais vraiment
une forme de société qui a des impacts
concrets et mesurables par exemple sur
les taux dans bouche des personnes notre
mission c'est le troisième point que je
voulais souligner en plus s'inscrit dans
un calendrier opportun
notre rapporteur monsieur bernard cazeau
ira plus loin dans l'analyse des
dispositifs de sécurité sanitaire et
dans ses recommandations et vous verrez
combien nous sommes dépendants des
règles européennes qui ont jusqu'à
présent plutôt privilégier la libre
circulation des biens et l'harmonisation
sur la sécurité sanitaire
mais nous avons la chance de tomber dans
un calendrier opportun puisque les
règles européennes sont aujourd'hui en
cours de révision et donc de
rediscussion alors à nous d'être force
de proposition dans ce cadre et nous
pouvons proposer une voie médiane entre
le système européen actuel parfois trop
libre échangiste mais facteur
d'innovation et le système américain que
certains voient comme un i deal mais qui
laisse quand même passer beaucoup de
scandales lui aussi qui peut être moins
favorable à l'innovation mais plus
sécurisé ont donc nous pouvons proposer
une voie médiane afin d'équilibrer
l'exigence d'innovation et l'impératif
de sécurité parce que au cours de ce
débat je pense que ce seront les deux
termes de notre débat sécurité et
innovation de principes qui doivent
guider notre réflexion
cet après midi comment faire en sorte
que des interventions non vital soit
engagé de la plus haute exigence de
sécurité tandis que les interventions
absolument vitale elle pourrait intégrer
une prise de risque un peu supérieure
je voudrais dans ce débat et en allant
peut-être sur le terrain des
propositions qui normalement relève du
rapporteur mentionné un sujet qui me
tient à coeur qui est celui des
perturbateurs endocriniens
il y à un peu plus d'un an notre
collègue gilbert barbier a consacré un
rapport sur ce sujet au nom de lopes qu
dont je cite simplement le titre
perturbateurs endocriniens le temps de
la précaution et on a coutume de dire
que les dispositifs médicaux ne sont pas
mieux encadrer que les jouets c'est vrai
pour le marquage ce et eux et en matière
de substances cancérogènes mutagènes et
reprotoxiques cmr c'est même pire elles
sont interdits dans les jouets elles
sont même interdite dans des produits de
ludique pour adultes mais l on entre
toujours dans la fabrication des
dispositifs médicaux et nous savons nous
avons aujourd'hui des études précise
d'ailleurs qui ont été présentés par le
professeur qui colle et là lors des
auditions que nous menons sur la ppl sur
le bisphénol a qui souligne l'impact
sanitaire catastrophique de ses produits
et tout particulièrement à l'aise sur
l'état du foetus du nourrisson et donc
du prématuré
aussi lors de l'examen de la proposition
de loi sur le disque enola je vous
proposerai que ce produit soit exclus
des dispositifs médicaux tout
particulièrement ceux qui touchent les
prématurés et les nourrissons enfin un
dernier mot sur l'esthétique que nous
avons découvert tout au long de nos
travaux est assez inquiétant pour ne pas
dire parfois effrayant inquiétant de
pression sociale de normalisation de
stratégie marketing qui ne font que
confirmer malheureusement ce que j'avais
déjà souligné son un précédent rapport
qui concerne l hyper sexualisation des
enfants
alors on pourrait s'interroger longtemps
sur les motivations des personnes qui
ont recours à la chirurgie ou à la
médecine esthétique et nos auditions ont
montré très clairement que tout laura
linney moralisation est inutile et elle
serait même totalement injuste vraiment
soutien avant qu'on commence ce débat a
rappelé ce point la modification des
corps la volonté de modifier les corps a
existé de
autant ça n'est pas un phénomène des
temps modernes ça n'est pas un problème
de société entre guillemets riches ça a
existé de tout temps et ça se
développera inévitablement avec le
vieillissement de la population
donc il faut même souhaité qu'on
parvienne à améliorer ses techniques
mais nous devons nous ici dans cet
hémicycle éclairer l'opinion
nous vous devons clarifier les
frontières entre l'esthétique et la
médecine et nous ne devons pas hésiter à
interdire quand le risque sanitaire est
avéré
mes chers collègues donc je vous invite
à un débat ouvert et pragmatique autour
de propositions que je qualifie très
audacieuse de notre rapporteur qui
améliore la sécurité sanitaire sans
entraves et les innovations entre
guillemets vital et améliore la
réglementation sont moralisation et une
fois de plus je pense
le sénat va montrer qu'il a un temps
d'avancé et j'ai même une minute
d'avancé sur mon temps je vous remercie
merci madame heures à porter la parole
est à monsieur bernard cazeau lui aussi
rapporteur de la mission commune
d'information
eh bien monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ce débat
bien en quelque sorte couronner le
travail de la mission commune
d'information sur les dispositifs
médicaux implantables et les
interventions visent esthétique était
créé d'ailleurs à l'initiative de
collection telles renault ou l'ignoré
pas à l'origine cette mission l'origine
cette mission se trouve l'émotion
suscitée par le scandale des prothèses
pip est notre rapport à d'ailleurs
montré combien cette triste affaire
dépassé le simple cadre d'une fraude au
gel de silicone pour recouvrir l'ampleur
d'un véritable scandale sanitaire
les dernières données de
matériovigilance publié en juillet par
l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament montre que les cas
d'anomalies et de réactions
inflammatoires sont plus importants
qu'estimé au fur et à mesure des
exploitations fin juillet 12345
française sur les trente mille
potentiellement concernés avait fait
retirer leurs prothèses dont 8460 à
titre préventif les anomalies ont été
constatées dans 22% des cas soit du près
du quart des opérations c'est beaucoup
plus que ce qui a été annoncé lorsque le
scandale a éclaté
voilà qui n'est pas de nature à rassurer
toutes les femmes qui souffrent d'autant
que la question de leur indemnisation
n'est toujours pas réglée de nombreux
autres raisons justifiées que le sénat
s'intéresse aux dispositifs médicaux
lors de la discussion de la loi sur le
médicament
plusieurs de nos collègues avaient
prédit qu'il serait au coeur du prochain
scandale sanitaire est faite nous ont
malheureusement rapidement donné réseau
c'est donc avec la volonté de prévenir
un nouveau scandale 5,4 notre mission
c'est d'appeler un travail de fond en
l'espace de quatre mois
nous avons auditionné plus de 50
institutions associations nôtres
reese qu'ils ont fait part de leurs
préoccupations au sujet astier vous
savez notre versant du champ de
compétences notre mission concernés les
interventions à visée esthétique
à ce titre l'ampleur inédite de la faire
pipi qui se traduit par une couverture
médiatique international sans précédent
a montré combien l'apparence et la
beauté fusse-t-elle artificiel était
devenu les préoccupations majeures sinon
essentiel d'un grand nombre de nos
contemporains
au delà des intérieurs des
interrogations relatives aux méthodes et
aux enjeux du contrôle des dispositifs
médicaux
cette affaire des prothèses pip n a donc
conduit à nous interroger sur la
réglementation des interventions à visée
esthétique
au fil de nos travaux et fort de
constatation d'un caractère parfois
absurdes dramatique ou désolant selon
les cas notre mission s'est attaché à
fort lui mais a formulé des propositions
concrètes avec un mot d'ordre faire
prévaloir la sécurité dès lors qu'il est
question de santé publique
on a déjà beaucoup parlé de notre
recommandation l'interdiction dès
cabines de bronzage
je n'en dirai donc un nom elles sont
aujourd'hui reconnu comme un facteur
d'augmentation des pathologies cutanées
notamment de la plus grave d'entre elles
le mélanome
donc quand expliqueront que le nombre de
morts est moins important que d'autres
activités comme la chasse où la baignade
est que les cabines sont moins nocif que
le tabac que personne n'a proposé
d'interdire jusqu'à présent c'est
exactement le genre d'argument entendu
au brésil lorsque ce pays a pris la
décision d'interdire les cabines
fin 2009 les intérêts en jeu sont loin
d'être négligeables
c'est vrai mais comme la considérer la
justice brésilienne
le droit à la santé doit prévaloir sur
le droit au libre exercice de l'activité
économique et l'interdiction est
toujours en vigueur en dépit de ce que
certains voudraient nous faire croire
il faut donc placer la sécurité en tête
de nos préoccupations de comment faire
s'agissant des produits des dispositifs
médicaux implantables la réponse n'est
pas toujours évidente car les nouvelles
technologies contribuent à sauver des
vies et à améliorer la qualité des soins
je pense par exemple à l'essor de la
cardiologie interventionnelle
lionel qui permet de traiter des
pathologies graves dans des conditions
beaucoup moins lourdes que les
techniques chirurgicales traditionnels
lorsqu'il en va de la vie du patient et
qu'il faut faut sans doute privilégier
la rapidité de mise sur le marché des
dispositifs innovants
quitte à procéder à leur évaluation
approfondie après implantation
hormis cyclable de ces cas d'urgence la
sécurité d'après valoir l'exemple de
pays paie ou des prothèses de hanche
depuis a montré les graves défaillances
des mécanismes de contrôle
la commission européenne a engagé une
vaste réforme des directives relatives
aux dispositifs
d'abord annoncée pour le printemps cette
révision de la réglementation européenne
a abouti la semaine dernière et c'est
important
je passe sur la proposition de règlement
relative aux diagnostics au dispositif
de diagnostic in vitro qui n'entraient
pas dans le champ de la mission
pour ce qui est des dispositifs médicaux
en général sous réserve d'une analyse
plus précise de la proposition de
règlement je note avec satisfaction que
la commission européenne partager les
préoccupations exprimées par notre
mission
début juin même jean no et moi même nous
étions d'ailleurs rendu à bruxelles pour
nous entretenir avec le cabinet du
commissaire à la santé et des
fonctionnaires ainsi que les
fonctionnaires de la direction générale
intéressés nous leur avions fait part de
notre volonté de voir la rigueur
s'imposent et à tous les niveaux afin de
garantir la sécurité du malade des
malades
d'une manière générale la commission
reprend ce qui fut le leitmotiv de la
mission tout au long de nos travaux
renforcer sensiblement les contrôles
pour garantir que seuls des dispositifs
sur sont placés sur le marché de l'union
européenne et dans le même temps
favoriser l'innovation et préserver la
compétitivité du secteur des dispositifs
médicaux
l'essentiel des commandes des
recommandations vous avions fait se
retrouve où sont reprises qu'andré sous
une forme ou une autre par la commission
je citerais notamment la surveillance
renforcée des organismes d'évaluation
préalablement
zen tout ce qu'ils voulaient la
multiplication des visites inopinées
chez les fabricants qui n'existait
jamais avant les premiers du genre et
avance permettait faire permis
l'histoire des prothèses pip d'ailleurs
l'accroissement des pouvoirs des
organismes notifiés
ils se rendent et ils vont avoir des
responsabilités et seront surveillés
plus particulièrement
d'après les perspectives annoncées
l'ouverture aux professionnels de santé
ou publics
c'est très important au public de la
base de données européenne eudamed à des
fins d'information et de transparence
sur les produits disponibles le
renforcement de la traçabilité par
l'introduction d'un système
d'identification unique des dispositifs
médicaux qui est en quelque chose qui
est très très heureux très en cour
aujourd'hui y compris aux états unis
lundi fiq l'intensification des
exigences relatives aux preuves
cliniques
parce que faire des dispositifs médicaux
sans avoir sans jamais avoir de preuves
cliniques c'est peut-être un petit peu à
l'encontre de dispositifs cela était
habituelle l'amélioration de la
coordination pour ça ils font parler
aussi entre autorités entre autorités
nationales de surveillance
enfin l'institution de règles de nature
à prévenir le forum shopping c'est à
dire la possibilité offerte un fabricant
de changer d'organisme notifié comme on
lis entre foi et ça a été l'histoire des
potées spi puis en changer d'organisme
notifié en cours de notification dans le
projet de la commission
ce changement passerait par un accord
signé par les trois parties
le fabricant l'ancien organisme notifié
et le nouveau l'acor remporterait
l'abrogation du marquage de conformité
délivré par l'ancien organisme
identifiés et se change rance et ce
changement seraient notifiées à la
mission encore une fois attendre d'avoir
le texte précise entre nos mains mais le
rapporteur que je suis ne peut
s'empêcher de penser que nous avons fait
oeuvre utile
reste que l'objectif de la commission
européenne est d'aboutir à l'adoption du
règlement d'ici à deux ans pour une
entrée en vigueur progressive entre 2015
et 2019
l'europe c'est encore plus longue chez
nous ce qui nous empêche pas mam le
ministre d'agir dès à présent et oui car
tout ne se joue pas à bruxelles trop
c'est trop facile en matière de suivi
des dispositifs après leur implantation
nous ne pouvons incriminé la
réglementation communautaire
si les défauts de conception des
protège-dents du puits depuis ont été
détectés en australie en suède et non
pas en france c'est parce que nous ne
tenons pas de registre exhaustif des
dispositifs il est indispensable et
urgent de repenser le système en rendant
le recueil de données plus simple en
appelant les professionnels de santé à
leurs responsabilités en la matière car
ils traînent des pieds
on nous a proposé que la création de
registre exhaustive se heurter aussi à
des difficultés juridiques mais nous
avons vérifié
elles peuvent être surmontés alors
madame la ministre
quelles initiatives entendez vous
prendre en ce domaine qui me paraît
fondamental c'est la première question
dans le même ordre d'idées il faut
simplifier la déclaration d'incident
grave et accroître la transparence des
liens d'intérêts
même si en matière de dispositifs
médicaux les choses ne sont pas aussi
simples que dans le domaine du
médicament car les nouveaux matériels
sont souvent développées en concertation
avec une équipe médicale voire à son
initiative la loi médicament contient
des dispositions intéressantes on l'a vu
cet été avec l'avertissement lancé par
l'asm sur les sondes de stimulation
cardiaque selon me dis qu apparemment
commercialisé en dépit du retrait ou du
non renouvellement des certificats de
marquage ce
par son organisme bonne chance à ceux à
qui on les a posés là nsm a d'ailleurs
demandé le mois dernier la mise en
quarantaine de l'ensemble des sommes de
ce fabricant que les établissements
santé pourrait avoir en stock
preuve que les mécanismes existants
peuvent fonctionner
par ailleurs madame la ministre dans
quel délai c'est une redemande
pourrons-nous disposer du rapport sur la
sécurité des dispositifs médicaux prévus
à l'article 41 de cette loi j'en viens
maintenant à l'esthétique pour ce qu'ils
à surgir citic la france fait figure
d'exemple le directeur de 15 jours
l'interdiction de la publicité
l'encadrement des interventions sont des
éléments essentiels dont plusieurs pays
cherchent à s'inspirer
en revanche en matière de médecine
esthétique c'est la jeune le marché en
forte croissance et de nouvelles
techniques apparaissent sans cesse il ya
quelques jours encore un nouvel appareil
est sorti sur le marché entre
parenthèses la brosse vibrante antirides
bros vivante
anti ride et oui madame boulet qui
facilite la pénétration de la crème de
jour
si vous voulez savoir tout savoir bel
exemple de marketing qui ce qui surf sur
la volonté universelle de retarder les
effets de l'âge la frontière entre les
actes accomplis par les professionnels
de santé médecin ou dentiste dans
certains cas parce que dans this
commence à reprendre ses juteux il
commença à déborder de la mâchoire et
ceux réalisés par les esthéticiennes
s'estompe 7 frontières s'estompent
il est difficile d'y voir clair
d'autant que si certains dangers sont
avérées d'autres risques ne sont qu'un
potentiel ce qui fait peser une
incertitude juridique sur les mesures
susceptibles d'être décidé ceci s'est
produit l'année dernière avait des
techniques de lyse adipocytaire dans la
suspicion de nocivité n'était qu'un
potentiel
le décret pris par le gouvernement en
avril 2011 a été en partie invalidée
peut-être pouvez-vous nous préciser
madame la ministre comment le
gouvernement entend reprendre ce dossier
tout en garantissant la solide et je la
solidité juridique des dispositions
prises en tout état de cause il faut
clarifier les choses et faire prévaloir
la sécurité en agissant dans plusieurs
directions
la première exigence consiste à réserver
les actes potentiellement dangereux aux
seuls médecins
ce devait être ce devrait être le cas
des procédés de dépilation par lampe à
lumière pulsée au delà d'une certaine
puissance parce que en dessous de cette
puissance là elles sont inefficaces dans
tout le monde peut s'y amuser il nous
faut aussi préciser les conditions de
formation des médecins esthétiques la
médecine esthétique doit pas constituer
une spécialité à part entière mais les
praticiens doivent disposer d'une
véritable capacité
il faut donc créer quand nous proposons
un desk diplôme d'études spécialisées
complémentaires dans ce domaine et ça
nous vous laissons la possibilité de
voir avec votre collègue du ministère de
l'éducation nationale puis france
domaine les deux ministères un concours
à la mise en heure il faut instituer un
marquage spécifique à l'esthétique
permettent permettre cela permettrait de
faire le ménage parmi tous ces produits
n'ayant aucune raison de disposer en
france d'une centaine de produits à base
d'acide hyaluronique alors qu'une
dizaine seulement et sur le marché aux
états unis
chacun propose sa petite recette sans
justification précise bien au contraire
il faut également constituer une base de
données de tous les dangers de ces
produits ou des actes proposer aux
consommateurs de sorte qu'ils les
fassent pratiqué en pleine connaissance
de cause
cette véritable esthétique au vigilance
passe enfin par la création d'un carnet
de soins esthétiques que nous proposons
afin que les personnes qui recourent à
ces techniques ne les multiplie pas de
manière
un prudente voire dangereuse voilà
madame la ministre
quelques-unes des pistes de réflexion
que nous avons dégagé dans un esprit de
responsabilité
assez unanime je terminerai en
soulignant que n'ont pas perdu de vue
l'incidence économique des secteurs
concernés ainsi que la nécessité de ne
pas entraver l'innovation mais il faut
vraiment replacer la sécurité au premier
rang des priorités comme le dit le vieil
adage latin primum non nocere et merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite du débat la parole est à madame
laurence cohen pour le groupe crc
madame la ministre chers collègues je
tiens tout d'abord à dire que je suis
satisfaite que suite au débat sur le
financement des hôpitaux nous puissions
aborder ce sujet en lui accordant une
place importante dans nos échanges car
ils relèvent bien lui aussi d'un enjeu
fondamental de notre système de santé
l'émotion suscitée depuis près d'un an
par le scandale des prothèses mammaires
pays p justifié pleinement la création
de cette mission d'information en
l'élargissant l'ensemble des dispositifs
médicaux implantables et aux
interventions à visée esthétique
les nombreuses auditions organisées par
cette mission ont été de qualité et
permet aujourd'hui d'avancer un certain
nombre de propositions de bon sens et
qui pourtant faisait cruellement défaut
jusqu'à présent
je tiens donc à remercier madame chantal
jouanno présidente de cette mission pour
le travail réalisé et monsieur bernard
cazeau pour son rapport ce nouveau
scandale sanitaire après celui du
médiator a mis une nouvelle fois en
lumière les dysfonctionnements matière
de réglementation et les intérêts
financiers qui peuvent primer sur la
santé des patients
il n'est pas acceptable que les lacunes
du système puisse permettre à quelqu'un
de déjouer pendant 20 ans tous les
contrôles par appétits financiers et
souci de rentabilité selon le bilan
réalisé en juillet dernier parle nsm l'
agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
plus de 3000 cas de rupture ont été
détectés chez des porteuses française et
plus de 2000 femmes ont bénéficié si je
puis dire d'un retrait préventif sur
trente mille femmes concernées cela nous
montre l'ampleur des dégâts nous savons
quelle est la souffrance tant physique
que psychologique vécue par ces femmes
et cela doit effectivement nous
interroger sur les mesures à prendre
pour éviter que cela ne se reproduise le
rapport montre très bien que malgré des
moratoires successifs de
commercialisation de cette technologie
depuis longtemps controversé malgré des
signaux d'alert les années se sont
écoulées sans qu'il y ait retrait et
suspension de la mise sur le marché et
l'utilisation sésame plan mammaires
fabriqués par la société pays p je suis
donc favorable comme préconisé dans le
rapport à ce que le gouvernement demande
à l'igas de dresser un
il en détail et de la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire je crois que cette
transparence même a posteriori est
essentiel pour les victimes et demain
pour de futurs patiente
il me paraît tout aussi important de
renforcer strictement les contrôles
effectués sur les dispositifs médicaux
implantables dès leur mise sur le marché
durant toute leur durée d'utilisation
en effet comme chacun le sait
contrairement aux médicaments dont la
mise en vente est conditionné par
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché à
elle même les dispositifs médicaux
peuvent être vendus
même en l'absence de tests nous avons
voulu renforcer cette pharmacovigilance
via la loi de décembre 2011 dite loi du
médicament les dispositifs médicaux font
également partie de cette loi mais six
mois après sa promulgation
les décrets d'application des articles
concernés ne sont toujours pas parus
peut-être que madame la ministre pourra
on pourrait nous éclairer sur ce point
d'auto toutefois avec intérêt que la
commission européenne vient de réviser
la réglementation sur les dispositifs
médicaux et les dispositifs médicaux de
diagnostic in vitro
les propositions de la commission vise
selon le commissaire européen à la santé
john dalli a renforcé je le cite
sensiblement les contrôles pour garantir
que seuls les dispositifs sur sont
placés sur le marché de l'union
européenne et dans le même temps à
favoriser l'innovation et à préserver la
compétitivité du secteur figurent en
outre parmi ces dispositions une
traçabilité totale des dispositifs les
plus sensibles et une surveillance
accrue du marché
c'est une décision importante même si
l'on peut regretter qu'il n'y ait
toujours pas de véritable autorisation
de mise sur le marché pour les
dispositifs à haut risque
l'investigation de la mission nous
également permis de nous interroger sur
ce que l'on appelle les interventions à
visée esthétique
ces nouvelles pratiques de plus en plus
nombreuses entre elles ou peuvent
entraîner de nouveaux dangers
il est de notre responsabilité de les
anticiper pour les éviter
il s'agit d'un véritable enjeu de
société à part entière un secteur
économique florissant avec plus de 11
millions soins de beauté et de bien-être
qui auraient été réalisées en france en
les femmes en sont le public majoritaire
notre rapport au corps au vieillissement
à la beauté entraîne un recours de plus
en plus fréquents et banalisé de ces
nouvelles techniques séduisante sans
penser aux conséquences à plus long
terme ou tout simplement parce que l'on
croit que ces pratiques sont très
encadrées et donc sans danger
il est vrai qu'il est difficile de
démontrer le caractère dangereux d'une
pratique esthétique
en l'absence de données scientifiques ou
de statistiques fiables et objectives
al'inverse on sait aujourd'hui
pertinemment que certaines pratiques
sont dangereuses je pense aux cabines de
bronzage dont les risques sont
aujourd'hui scientifiquement avérée nous
pouvons les ignorer je partage donc la
proposition d'interdiction de ces
cabines hors usage médical comme le
recommande la mission c'est certes une
mesure radicale et sans doute
impopulaires mais nécessaires pour
éviter un futur scandale sanitaire
sans revenir sur chacune des 38
propositions formulées par la mission
nous devons d'une manière générale et
pour l'avenir répondre à trois priorités
d'abord bien définir les responsabilités
en matière d'évaluation de contrôle et
de surveillance des dispositifs médicaux
la rsm doit pouvoir pleinement à ce
titre joué son rôle de gendarme
sanitaire en centralisant tous les
signalements
deuxièmement crée les conditions d'une
formation qualifiante des professionnels
cette demande est redevenu très souvent
dans les auditions
troisièmement avoir un statut bien
définis dans les frontières pourtant
assez floue entre le médical et
l'esthétique
enfin pour notre part nous leur dirons
jamais assez il est impératif de mettre
fin aux conflits d'intérêts qui peuvent
exister
excusez moi le rhume attaque
et renforcer les contrôles et les
inspections réalisées par les organismes
notifiés ces organismes doivent avoir
les moyens de remplir leur mission ce
qui n'est à l'heure actuelle pas le cas
les fabricants pouvant décider eux mêmes
des modalités de certification et
d'évaluation une harmonisation par le
haut est donc nécessaire au niveau
européen tout comme une indépendance
renforcée de ces structures de contrôle
j'en profite également pour dire qu'il
est primordial de protéger les lanceurs
d'alert comme stipulé là encore dans la
loi sur le médicament pour éviter les
attaques virulentes dont les
professionnels de santé peuvent être
victimes dans de telles situations
heureusement que j'arrive à la
conclusion en conclusion nous partageons
donc pleinement la philosophie de ce
rapport bien résumé dans le titre santé
beauté une priorité la sécurité je vous
remercie
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
madame nathalie goulet pour le groupe uc
r
monsieur le président madame le ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je
regrette que notre débat n'ait pas
attiré plus de monde mais en même temps
ma confession sera plus discrète
l'idée de vieillir massue porte
complètement comble mandri de
liposuccion botox acide lifting système
filaire tous ces procédés me sont
familiers car voyez vous même le
ministre jean suis-je l'avouer ces
consommatrices et depuis un certain
temps j'ajoute que végétarienne j'ai une
pratique quotidienne du sport et je
pratique le jeune thérapeutique depuis
environ une trentaine d'années dire que
mon image m'importe est un euphémisme
vous comprendrez donc l'appétence que
j'ai eue pour cette commission
d'information et que je concentre
évidemment mon propos sur la médecine
esthétique la philosophie pour ne pas
dire la psychologie du consommateur est
identique en réalité parce que la
chirurgie évidemment à ce caractère
réparateur et parfois beaucoup plus
grave est beaucoup plus sérieux mais en
réalité une partie là la patientèle
s'agissant de la chirurgie a aussi la
même le même type de philosophie si je
parle de consommateurs c'est sous le
diktat de l'apparence de la mode de
l'éternelle jeunesse la notion de
patience et face à mon sens ce devant
celle du consommateur nous sommes passés
de faust à l'incroyable famille
kardashian dans un marché et une
véritable société de consommation en
2008 le rapport le mentionne et beaucoup
en ont fait aussi mention ses 500
milliards de dollars aux états unis dont
100 milliards pour les soins de lutte
contre le vieillissement ce n'est pas
rien la france arrive seulement qu'un
furet seulement au 14e rang sur les pays
les plus consommateurs aux états unis
encore 9 millions de dhs intervention
était pratiquée en 2011 dont 1 milliard
700 milles pour les injections dont on
verra plus tard notamment en france et
le rapporteur en a fait état qu'en
réalité vous avez des injections d'un
certain nombre de produits qui ne sont
évidemment pas contrôler c'est toujours
très très sécurisant en france en 2009
actes de chirurgie et de médecine
esthétique ont été réalisés par environ
465 chirurgie quant aux actes de
médecine esthétique la croissance et
continué constante plus tout ce qui
concerne l'esthétique là aussi il ya eu
du monde j'y reviendrai pas le rapport
en fait longuement état de ses
esthéticiennes qui sont à la limite à la
frontière avec la médecine esthétique et
là aussi il n'est pas question de
stigmatiser une profession mais il ya
quand même des choses à faire sans
parler des cabines de bronzage qui sont
dans les clubs de gym ou autres
établissements où ils n'auraient
évidemment rien à y faire
d'abord parce que ce n'est pas l'endroit
et ensuite parce que comme les autres
membres de la commission je me suis
rangé à l'avis du rapporteur s'agissant
de leur interdiction ça c'est des g
quelque chose que je n'utilisais pas
donc gros chiffres en effet de 3
millions 3 milliards d'euros il va sans
dire que ces montants démontre que le
secteur de l'esthétique médicale est
bien engagée sur la voie de la
banalisation marché avec ses règles de
l'offre et de la demande de ses bons et
ses mauvais élèves de ses consommateurs
avec ou sans modération et de ses
addictions l'âme et sting la médecine
esthétique connaît tous sa les journaux
les publicités par internet sont des
vecteurs inépuisable là où aussi madame
le ministre pense que les pouvoirs
publics auraient beaucoup à faire
je parle n'a même pas citer encore les
bars pour le blanchiment des dents et
autres choses de cet acabit qui vont
nous réserver de très très mauvaises
surprises dans l'avenir les hommes sont
d'ailleurs et c'est très réconfortant de
plus en plus consommateurs notamment
pour les problèmes de calvitie c'est
bien normal donc quelques pistes plus
sérieusement mais en fait nous sommes
entre nous donc nous pouvons bien dans
cet hémicycle et à la veille d'un projet
de loi sur le du plfss et du budget qui
ne nous entraînera pas à beaucoup de
sourires prendre ce débat avec la
philosophie et la distance qui
s'imposent j'ai été malade dans le passé
vice-présidente également de la
commission sur le médiator et nous
n'avions pu que regretter l'absence
totale d'attention qui avaient été
portées aux propositions qui avaient été
faites à l'époque dans un rapport de
antérieure de 10 ans concernant le vioxx
et nous avons connu dans le médiator
exactement le même type de problème qui
s'il avait été prise à temps aurait
probablement évité de nombreuses
difficultés s'agissant du médiator donc
la première proposition que j'ai à vous
faire pour éviter les mêmes causes
produisant les mêmes effets ce même type
de carence le même type d'erreur et
malheureusement le même nombre de
victimes parce que c'est quand même de
cela qu'on parle ma famille je
souhaiterais que nous puissions mettre
en place une espèce de cellule
permanente de suivi des propositions qui
ont été faites dans ce rapport et du
travail qui est fait par notre haute
assemblée de façon à créer un lien
constant pas forcément institutionnels
pas forcément lourd pas forcément unique
6ème commission où les parlementaires
vous le savez ont du mal à se rendre
parce que parfois leurs obligations sont
nombreuses mais je crois qu'il faudrait
arriver à créer une cellule permanente
de eu de suivi des propositions qui ont
été faites en tous les cas dans ce
domaine la seconde proposition concerne
l'information complète et la
communication institutionnelle je dirais
cohérente et continue la volonté
politique d'alerter le public sur les
dangers de ces pratiques pourraient
commencer par une vaste communication
des médecins et de l'ensemble des
pouvoirs publics
nous avons connu avec beaucoup de succès
la campagne des antibiotiques ce n'est
pas automatique
nous pourrions aussi martelé que la
chirurgie la médecine esthétique est un
acte grave pour avoir des conséquences
sur la santé qui ne relève pas et j'y
reviendrai de la solidarité nationale en
tous les cas pour une bonne partie
d'entre elles une règlement appliquer
une réglementation appliquée renforcée
en ce qui concerne les remboursements là
aussi
je pense qu'il est extrêmement important
d'une part de réserver les actes
présentant des risques sérieux au
médecin qualifié le rapporteur en a
parlé c'est une évidence
et de ce point de vue là le législateur
a confié au pouvoir réglementaire le
soin de déterminer les règles de
formation de qualification applicable
aux personnes habilitées à exécuter des
interventions avisés et si vous avez
madame dans vos tiroirs à décret en
gestation
créé par l'article 61 de la loi hôpital
patients santé territoires et modifiant
l'article 11 51 2 du code de la santé
publique qui dispose que la pratique des
actes procédés techniques des méthodes à
visée esthétique autres ce que ceux
relevant de l'article 63 22 un peu si
elle présente des risques sérieux pour
la santé des personnes être soumise à
des règles définies par décret moi je
vous propose madame le ministre de
supprimer le si ça ne coûte rien c'est
assez rapide et ça institut la volonté
politique de marque et que les décisions
ou que les mesures de chirurgie ou de
médecine esthétique sont par définition
des actes présentant des risques sérieux
pour la santé je crois que c'est simple
et c'est le marqueur d'une d'une volonté
politique de ne pas banaliser ces actes
de médecine esthétique parce que parmi
ces actes il faut quand même les cités
c'est normal qu'il soit réservé aux
médecins vous avez les comblements par
injection de tout produit utilisation de
dispositifs de techniques des
rayonnements électromagnétiques ou
d'ultrasons vous avez tout un tas de
dispositifs d'amincissement liposuccion
et autres vous avez le traitement de
lésions cutanées par des dispositifs
aussi électromagnétiques ex rg pas
reprendre la liste enfin si vous prenez
l'ensemble des dispositions vous voyez
que c'est quand même sont quand même des
mesures qui sont assez lourdes et qui
nécessite une alerte du public je crois
que si le décret pouvait par principe
considéré que ces actes n'étaient pas
des procédés banal je crois que nous y
gagnerons lyon en rapidité
donc je vous propose donc de retirer le
site de ce décret à intervenir
naturellement il est important que les
mesures s'agissant de la formation phare
prise mais le rapporteur en a parlé
je voudrais aussi souligner que
l'appétence pour pour cette médecine
entraîne une autre difficulté qui
rejoint un peu le problème que nous
avions avec l'hôpital et que nous
trouverons dans le plfss qui est dans un
contexte d'aggravation des déséquilibres
de la démographie médicale
l'augmentation des demandes de soins
esthétiques et susceptibles d'intéresser
un grand nombre de médecins généralistes
est perçue l'avons vu pendant les
auditions comme une cause probable est
possible d'augmentation de l'aggravation
des risques de désertifier de
désertification médicale
est-ce que je crois que là aussi il faut
être bien vigilant sur la façon dont on
dont on procède donc pour conclure je
voudrais revenir sur le point que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure s'agissant des
remboursements l'acceptation du risque
pour un client patient consommateur
n'est pas le même selon qu'il s'agit
d'un acte à visée esthétique ou d'une
chirurgie réparatrice en conséquence il
faudrait interdire est en tous les cas
contrôler les remboursements des actes à
visée esthétique et des conséquences je
pense notamment aux opérations de
confort d'une équipe passe ici ou là
pour un déplacement de cloisons et
autres petites tricheries qui finalement
pèse sur le budget de la sécurité
sociale et sur la collectivité alors
qu'ils n'ont rien à y faire et qu'on a
déjà bien assez de soucis et
déséquilibre des comptes sociaux comme
ça je pense aussi et c'est beaucoup plus
grave et je pense que là aussi le
ministère a rapidement des mesures à
prendre à une très grande proportion de
soins qui sont exécutés en france et qui
sont relatifs à des opérations
esthétiques réalisés à l'étranger
ce tourisme esthétique à l'étranger
entraîne à peu près 20% de soins sur le
territoire national qu'à quand les gens
rentrent de thaïlande du liban ou
d'ailleurs et que les opérations ne se
sont pas bien passées
c'est à la charge de la collectivité
nationale qu'ils se font soigner ici et
moi je trouve
que ce système est absolument anormal je
vois pas pourquoi notre système de santé
parce que les soins post opératoires
d'une opération de chirurgie esthétique
se serait mal passé en thaïlande au
brésil ou ailleurs pèserait sur nos
comptes sociaux je trouve ça tout à fait
anormal et je déposerai dans le cadre du
plfss un certain nombre d'amendements
sur ce sujet donc je crois qu'il
faudrait plutôt communiquer avec le
public que réglementer et j'en aurai
terminé en vous disant malin parce que
sur ces sujets je pense que
l'intégration dans notre dispositif
juridique de la class action et les
actions de groupe devient de plus en
plus nécessaire je crois qu'on ne peut
pas laisser des patients isolés des
clients isolés alors là c'est plutôt
pour les actes de chirurgie mais je
pense aux prothèses pip et je crois
qu'on peut pas laisser des victimes
alors je parle pas seulement de
problèmes de chirurgie là le fraude est
encore beaucoup plus grave
dans mon département je ne peux pas vous
dire combien de gens sont visés par
l'amiante et ce genre de choses vous ne
pouvez pas laisser des gens seuls face
au système judiciaire face à des
entreprises face à des gens qui ont
beaucoup plus de moyens pour se défendre
je crois que ce type de dossiers comme
les prothèses et ip comme donné
l'occasion de ce rapport sont vraiment
l'occasion de repenser céation groupe je
crois que c'est extrêmement important
enfin cette mission était totalement
passionnante menée de main de maître par
notre présidente chantal jouanno et par
le rapporteur
ceux qui me connaissent dans cette
maison savent que je n'ai pas l'habitude
de dire ce que je ne pense pas et donc
merci madame la présidente pour avoir
obtenu mener à bon port sans doute pour
une escale que j'espère temporaire cette
mission je voudrais aussi remercier tout
particulièrement notre administrateur
olivier jacque qui a été d'une
efficacité absolument remarquable merci
de votre attention
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
monsieur gilbert barbier pour le groupe
rdse
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je par
rapport à ma collègue qui m'a précédé je
ne suis pas utilisateurs de produits à
visée esthétique à préciser les choses
tout de suite je tiens néanmoins
félicité chantal jouanno et bernard
cazeau pour l'excellent travail qu'ils
ont accompli avec les très nombreuses
auditions qu'elles ont procédé qui ont
permis de faire un tour assez complet de
ce problème difficile
le scandale des prothèses pip est à
l'origine la création de la mission a
provoqué une onde de choc dans l'opinion
publique en france et dans le monde
entier et il a soulevé de nombreuses
interrogations comment un fabricant
peut-il pendant des années abusé
l'organisme qui lui délivre le label
cieux pourquoi les pouvoirs publics qui
ont ils pris aucune mesure lorsqu'en
2000 l'autorité sanitaire fédérale des
états unis la cia ayant constaté que la
société ne respectait pas les normes
sanitaires en vigueur avait interdit
l'utilisation de ces implants sur son
territoire pourquoi la sorte
n'at-elle pas demander le retrait des
implants que trois ans après avoir été
alertés par plusieurs chirurgiens
quelques temps après le drame du
médiateur le scandale des prothèses
mammaires a ébranlé la confiance des
médecins et des patients dans la ce dans
la cette confiance dans la surveillance
des dispositifs médicaux et a ainsi
relancé la polémique sur la sécurité
sanitaire dans notre pays
certes il s'agissait en l'occurrence
d'une fraude délibérée organisée par un
fabricant sans scrupules qui je veux
espérer reste un cas isolé et ne jette
pas l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des
fabricants de dispositifs de santé
pour autant les travaux menés par la
mission ont mis en évidence la faiblesse
notre système de surveillance et le
contrôle est dispo
étude prédit qu qui ne permet pas en
l'état d'éviter les malversations ni les
défectuosités je pense entre autres ça a
été évoqué par le rapporteur au problème
des chambres de qualitair mais aussi des
prothèses de hanche depuis ni les
pratiques à visée esthétique qui s'avère
dangereuse il y à peine un an lors de
l'examen du projet relatif au
renforcement la sécurité sanitaire du
médicament et des produits de santé
nous étions quelques-uns demander un
meilleur encadrement des dispositifs
médicaux convaincu de l'insuffisance
dans ce secteur ces craintes se sont
malheureusement avérées fondées et nous
impose de renforcer notre réglementation
afin de garantir pleinement la sécurité
des patients le rapport de la mission
préconise 38 recommandations parmi
lesquelles certaines me semble
particulièrement importante
j'en ai vous créé quelques unes il
convient tout d'abord de reconsidérer
les conditions de mise sur le marché des
dispositifs médicaux
contrairement aux médicaments les
dispositifs médicaux même la classe 3
qui ont un potentiel très sérieux de
risque ne requiert pas d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché mais une simple
certification celle délivrée par l'un
des soixante dix sept organismes de
contrôle accrédité par les autorités
compétentes de chaque état de l'union
européenne
il apparaît que certains organismes que
conciliant que d'autres ont la
réputation de ne refuser aucun dossier
il est donc aisé pour une entreprise peu
scrupuleuses de faire appel à l'un de
ses laboratoires pour obtenir son
accréditation
dans ces conditions il est évident que
les critères d'agrément des organismes
notifiés doivent être revues
d'autant que le marquage ce et eux ne
signifie pas que le produit est fabriqué
en europe et ne présume en rien de la
qualité du dispositif les dispositifs
médicaux de type 1 et 2 ne sont pas
soumis à la réglementation à la
réalisation d'essais cliniques prouvant
leur innocuité certes et son très long
me fabriquer pas plupart par des petites
entreprises qui n'ont pas les moyens de
procéder à ces essais subordonner la
certification des niveaux dispositifs
médicaux aux risques et à la réalisation
d'essais cliniques préalables
permettrait pourtant la création d'une
liste positive comme ça a été évoqué
véritable gage de transparence et de
sécurité
dans le même esprit et je rejoins le
rapporteur il est indispensable de
multiplier les contrôles surtout
inopinés la sécurité des dispositifs
médicaux implantables impose également
une plus grande exigence au niveau de la
matériaux sur matériovigilance la
question de l'indépendance de l'agencé
nationale de son sécurité du médicament
et des produits de santé et de ses
experts doit être clairement posée cette
agence est en cours de restructuration
laissons-lui peut-être un peu de temps
pour se lancer dans une un contrôle
efficace
il serait également souhaitable de
favoriser la mise en place de registres
de traçabilité comme il en existe
notamment en australie ou dans certains
pays nordiques ça a été évoqué dans le
rapport
le registre est en effet un instrument
important pour détecter les éventuelles
défaillances et donner l'alerté
cela impose toutefois la participation
des praticiens utilisateurs dans ce
domaine il faut bien reconnaître que la
france accuse un retard considérable
serait toutefois nécessaire à faible
coûte dans un premier temps madame
luminis c'est d'adopter un codage plus
précis du pmsi afin de mettre en place
un véritable suivi de l'utilisation des
dispositifs médicaux implantables à
l'hôpital ce qui n'est pas le cas à
l'heure actuelle il ya quelques jours à
peine c'est évoquer la commission
européenne a adopté une réglementation
stricte pour les dispositifs médicaux
implantables qui devrait permettre une
traçabilité totale pour les dispositifs
les plus sensibles et une serre
veillance accrue du marché en renforçant
la matériovigilance
je ne peux que me féliciter de cette
première étape espère vivement que ces
propositions seront rapidement validé
par le parlement européen
s'agissant des dispositifs médicaux à
visée esthétique il est indispensable de
clarifier les compétences de renforcer
la réglementation de responsabiliser le
former les praticiens dans un domaine
qui évolue sans cesse et où la demande
est le plus en plus pressante
on l'a bien vu quelques minutes en
france il existe plus d'une centaine de
produits injectables de comblement des
rides soumis à la certification cieux
alors causé ni aux états unis la f10 et
n'a délivré que six autorisations
considérant à juste titre que de tels
produits doivent répondre aux mêmes
exigences qu'un médicament
on peut s'étonner que les cabines de
bronzage de le danger est avéré puisse
encore relever de la compétence des
professionnels de l'esthétique un
encadrement rigoureux des pratiques doit
être mise en place d'une manière urgente
madame la ministre je crois que les
travaux de cette mission commune
d'information qui ont été menées avec
beaucoup de sérieux et de précision ont
démontré l'impérieuse nécessité de
renforcer les dispositifs de contrôle
des récentes dispositions de l'europe
l'onu guider dans cette voie agissant
sans tarder merci merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à madame aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la mission
commune d'information sur le rapporteur
chers collègues
l'automne dernier le sénat menait une
belle bataille sur le projet de loi
relatif à la sécurité sanitaire du
médicament et des produits de santé
le texte sorti en première lecture de
notre assemblée comportait des avancées
audacieuse mais néanmoins indispensables
à la sécurité de notre système de santé
porté par le rapporteur bernard cazeau
mais également par les sénateurs
socialistes écologistes et communistes
malheureusement ces dispositions ne
figure pas pratiquement pas dans le
texte finalement promulguée
puisque le travail de renforcement du
dispositif de sécurité sanitaire a
littéralement été taillés en pièces à
l'assemblée nationale en seconde lecture
les problèmes ne sont donc toujours pas
réglé d'autant plus que la plupart des
décrets d'application de cette loi n'ont
pas encore été pris les problèmes ne
sont toujours pas réglés et cela est
inquiétant c'est pour cela que notre
groupe souscrit entièrement aux 38
propositions faites par le rapport qui
nous est aujourd'hui présenté ainsi
qu'aux analyse qu'il fait nous
souhaitons notamment attirer votre
attention madame la ministre chers
collègues sur le fait que l'afssaps a
clairement dysfonctionné sur la sphère
des prophètes des prothèses pip est
comme sur d'autres affaires auparavant
sans que les leçons ont soit toujours
tirés monsieur cazaux votre rapport le
précise clairement dès la deuxième page
dès 2001 9 déclarations de chirurgiens
ont été transmises à l'afssaps relevant
notamment des cas de rupture et des
événements indésirables de même ampleur
ont été signalés à l'afssaps au cours
des années suivantes
pourtant il a fallu attendre 2010 pour
que l' agence décide le retrait la
suspension de la mise sur le marché des
implants fabriqué par la société pt
l'enchaînement des événements montrent
de graves déficiences dans la
circulation de l'information
le système de sécurité sanitaire
français n'est pas assez fiable lé
lanceur d'alert vive
véritable parcours du combattant leur
cri d'alarmé restent vains ils sont
victimes de multiples tentatives de
déstabilisation et d'intimidation en
plus du fait de voir souvent leurs
compétences remise en cause
partant de ce constat ma collègue marie
christine blandin présentera le 15
octobre au sénat une proposition de loi
qui permettrait de renforcer la qualité
de l'expertisé scientifique et la
protection des lanceurs d'alert le sénat
aurez alors l'occasion d'agir réellement
pour la sécurité sanitaire des français
je profite également de ce débat pour
insister sur les inégalités de santé et
les injustices
concernant ce dossier des prothèses pip
et d'autres collègues l'ont dit avant
moi car ce que souligne ce rapport c'est
que de nombreuses victimes de la firme
frauduleuse pays paie sont aujourd'hui
confrontés à des difficultés financières
graves
le rapport le dit explicitement
certaines victimes se trouvent dans
l'impossibilité de faire face au coût
des opérations chirurgicales voire même
d'avancer les sommes par la suite prise
en charge pour la collectivité au titre
des seuls explantation elles vivent donc
dans l' angoisse ne connaissant pas
l'état des prothèses qu'elle porte
d'autant que comme le rapport le précise
la découverte d'un taux de rupture plus
élevé que celui qui était anticipé
valide pourtant le choix d'une
exploitation généralisée ne serait ce
qu'en raison de considérations
financières privilégiées le suivi
régulier des femmes porteuses de
prothèses pip et pays par rapport à leur
exploitation immédiate pourrait s'avérer
à long terme plus coûteux pour la
collectivité
notre groupe estime donc que le scandale
continue qu'une barrière sociale
s'oppose à la sécurité de certaines
victimes
c'est une forme d' obstacles à l'accès
aux soins et nous espérons madame la
ministre que tout sera mis en oeuvre
pour y remédier enfin dans l'ensemble
des propositions faites par le rapport
l'une attire principalement mon
attention il s'agit de la proposition 5
relative à l'interdiction des cmr
cancérogènes mutagènes reprotoxiques de
4e catégorie 2 dans les dispositifs
médicaux destinés ou nous
ils sont jeunes enfants et femmes
enceintes cette proposition est
importante et je pense même que nous
pourrions et devrions aller plus loin
prenons l'exemple du des oeufs
hp une forme de phtalates justement
classées cmr niveau 2 par l'union
européenne dans l'ombre de ses
applications
le pvc est plastifié à l'aide de cette
substance pourtant interdite depuis 2005
dans tous les jouets aux enfants de
moins de 3 ans toutefois ils entrent
actuellement pour plus de 50% dans la
composition des plastiques à usage
médical poches de sang masques à oxygène
sont gastrique etc
or il est prouvé que le 10e hp n'est pas
chimiquement liés au pvc est donc s'en
échappe en continu qu'il est d'une
grande liposolubles bilité est
particulièrement bien absorbé et que
dans l'organisme sa distribution et
rapide
en 2008 le rapport du comité
scientifique des risques sanitaires
émergents et nouveaux à d'ailleurs
proposé une liste de procédures
médicales à haut potentiel d'exposition
aux dieux hp et a fait état de risques
particuliers
l'intoxication aiguë en soins intensifs
de néonatalogie où les nouveau-nés
reçoivent des doses des dieux hp pouvant
atteindre jusqu'à 20 fois la dose
journalière tolérable
très attaché aux principes établis
depuis hippocrate et rappelait il ya
quelques minutes par bernard cazeau ne
pas nuire et ensuite seulement soigner
notre groupe au sénat demande à ce que
la recherche des solutions alternatives
et accessible financièrement à
l'utilisation de phtalates soient
encouragés afin que cette substance soit
éliminée au plus vite des hôpitaux et
plus largement de tout usage médical ou
soignants je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue dernier orateurs
inscrits monsieur rené paul savary pour
l'ump
monsieur le président madame elle domine
isma la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les des
sénateurs s'étaient auparavant mais ça
mérite d'être encore souligné ce rapport
d'information est véritablement de
grande qualité il est clair certaines
pratiques qui mérite une adaptation pour
garantir la confiance des utilisateurs
ou des passions c'est donc bien vous
l'avez souligné chantal jouanno un enjeu
sociétal le travail accompli était
indispensable mais il est également
édifiant indispensable parce que notre
système français d'autorisation et de
surveillance ne correspond plus aux
enjeux d'aujourd'hui et sans être un
adepte du principe de précaution à tout
prix je ne suis pas non plus un
contemplatif des mauvaises pratiques
je m'explique certaines règles existent
bien organismes notifiés pour accréditer
des dispositifs la matériovigilance nous
en avons déjà parlé
les registres les études scientifiques
randomisés comparative
le kodak tu déjà qu à travers les pm et
si le programme de médicalisation des
systèmes d'information notamment dans
les hôpitaux les investigations
cliniques les rapport bénéfice/risque la
formation des praticiens les
enseignements diplômant etc bref toutes
ces règles mesure contraintes parfois
inspire à priori la confiance est en
fait elles ne sont pas adaptées à la
situation actuelle et deviennent même
source de défiance il nous faudra donc
prendre en compte les préconisations
proposées sans pénaliser la recherche et
le développement mais en redonnant
confiance aux sujets âgés alors pourquoi
maintenant ce travail est-il édifiant il
ya parce qu'il révèle les failles de
notre organisation sanitaire ou
paramédical
là encore je m'explique les quelques
auditions auxquelles j'ai participé
ont surpris des enjeux différents animés
ces débats chacun chacun étant persuadé
d'amener sa juste pierre à un édifice
qui en fait et globalement défaillant
cela a pu être constaté je voudrais
rajouter s'il le fallait
quelques exemples les registres les
registres existe bien mais dans d'autres
pays
il permettrait d'assurer une
surveillance car un des grands défauts
du système est l'absence de réactivité
dans le suivi des implantations et la
détection d'éventuels dysfonctionnements
les organismes notifiés
ils n'ont pas l'indépendance suffisante
semble-t-il pour garantir la neutralité
de leur expertise
le demandeur ayant le libre choix de
l'organisme
c'est ce qui va effectivement à l
encontre des principes de neutralité
les cahiers des charges les cahiers des
charges sont réduits en cas de
composants similaires
pas forcément identique il peut y avoir
des différences de réaction d'un
organisme à l'autre des effets
indésirables liés à deux des différences
moléculaire parfois même minime les flux
financiers
il ne semble pas suffisamment
transparent entre fabricants de
dispositifs médicaux et les laboratoires
ce qui nécessitera bien sûr
clarification
les contrôles et contrôles sont prévus
on l'a dit mais les organismes sont
prévenus avant leur passage
il n'y a pas encore un marquage européen
spécifique garantit la mise en ligne des
informations essentielles bien entendu
pour la sécurité n'est pas suffisamment
développée etc
de nombreux cas ont déjà été signalés
personnellement j'ai beaucoup appris
devant ces auditions et je voulais
témoigner du travail accompli
nul ne détient la vérité dans ce domaine
là mais chacun en détient quand même un
petit peu et le but de ce rapport met la
main
la ministre est véritablement de
replacer l'usagé dans un cadre
réglementaire mieux adaptés sans bloquer
l'innovation toujours est essentielle
en comparant avec ce qui se fait
ailleurs et en faisant des propositions
objectifs tout en conciliant des
intérêts divergents ce qui illustre bien
la difficulté d'un exercice qui me
paraît réussi à condition qu'il en soit
tenu compte
il en va de la crédibilité de nos
institutions dans le cadre de ses
pouvoirs régaliens de sécurité et de
contrôle
madame la ministre merci de nous donner
votre vision sur ces propositions émises
merci monsieur sa marine
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
tout d'abord permettez moi de renouvelé
les excuses de madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé qui est
donc qui est retenue par le séminaire
intergouvernemental sur la modernisation
de l'état qui se tient à matignon
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
pour ce rapport extrêmement documenté et
riche en enseignements
le temps et l'attention que votre
mission à accorder au domaine des
dispositifs médicaux implantables et aux
interventions à visée esthétique est
d'une aide précieuse pour
l'approfondissement de notre réflexion
sur ces domaines mais plus largement
encore sur la manière dont nous pouvons
assurer la protection de la santé de nos
concitoyens
il n'est pas inutile de rappeler le
contexte qui a provoqué le déclenchement
de cette mission le point de départ vous
avez été nombreux à le rappeler la
découverte de prothèses mammaires les
prothèses pip et qui était produite de
manière totalement contraire aux
procédures d'agrément du produit cette
affaire est dans les mains de la justice
et il ne nous appartient pas là de la
commenter
toutefois
à cette occasion les lacunes de la
réglementation des dispositifs médicaux
ont été pointés que ce soit au niveau
national comme au niveau européen
vous avez aussi très justement élargi
votre mission d'information des
dispositifs implantables aux
interventions esthétiques dont
l'encadrement est actuellement
extrêmement léger le dispositif médical
vous le dit fort justement doit être
considéré différemment du médicament
mais que ses produits s'adressent à des
malades ou des noms balade et comme pour
le médicament nous estimons que la
sécurité des personnes doit être au
centre du processus de leur mise et de
leur maintien sur le marché
vous l'avez monsieur barbier très bien
souligné il est vrai que ces dispositifs
recouvre des situations très diverses et
nous ne pouvons pas traiter de la même
manière des produits externes et très
courants comme les pansements ou les
bandages et des appareils implantés dans
le corps tels les sondes ou les implants
du type de la prothèse pip et dont nous
avons parlé un autre point dont il
faudra dont il nous faudra tenir compte
est la spécificité du tissu industriel
des fabricants de dispositifs médicaux
qui repose essentiellement sur des
petites et moyennes entreprises
ce secteur est porteur d'innovation
favorable à des progrès dans la prise en
charge des patients qu'il ne faut donc
pas contrainte sans un examen minutieux
je pense que cela répond à l'un de vos
souhaits monsieur savary la demande de
soins esthétiques est en forte
croissance de la part de la population
du fait notamment des progrès des
techniques utilisées et aussi de la
pression sociétale
madame vous en est un exemple quasi
parfait et ce besoin s'exprime dans une
population plus jeune qu auparavant
essentiellement féminine mais également
vous l'avez souligné
masculine soucieuse de son apparence
physique encouragé en cela par la
diffusion dans les médias d'image de
perfection madame jouanno vous avez eu
l'occasion de le rappeler
c'est ainsi que le monde de l'esthétique
s'est métamorphosée au cours des dix
dernières années l'offre commerciale et
les utilisateurs n'ont cessé d'augmenter
en 2010 13,4 pour cent des français
entre 15 et 75 ans déclaraient avoir
fait l'usagé au moins une fois dans leur
vie des ultraviolets artificiels
les cabines de bronzage recensés sont au
nombre de 18 mille
mais une étude de marché en dénombre 40
milles sur le territoire national la
simplicité apparente des procédures et
les gains qu'elle rapporte attire des
médecins et d'autres personnes
d'horizons multiples vers le métier de
l'esthétique
cependant les produits et les actes à
visée esthétique ne sont pas exempts de
risques sanitaires
on peut citer les prothèses mammaires
pip et les infections localisées voir
généralisé après des gestes invasifs mal
maîtrisé la multiplication de cancer de
la peau
suite aux expositions non contrôlée au
rayonnement des installations de
bronzage artificiel
c'est en cela que votre mission est d'un
apport essentiel car elles attirent
l'attention sur les risques encourus
dans un domaine qui paraît aux yeux de
nos concitoyens comme simplement facteur
de bien-être qui explique peut-être
pourquoi il ya si petit note sénateurs
ce soir vous avez conduit un travail
approfondi
oui je pense qu'ils iront ils y ont
recours vous avez conduit un travail
approfondi il serait vain de vouloir
résumer en quelques minutes à la fois
l'analyse produite et les
recommandations qui en sont issus
cependant quelques constats mérite
d'être souligné car il conditionne le
sens de l'action que nous devons mener
tout d'abord nous sommes face à une
réglementation européenne qui repose
plus sur le principe de libre
circulation des produits que sur le
principe de sécurité des personnes ce
qui devrait pourtant
être privilégiée s'agissant ici de
produits de santé ensuite le système de
mise sur le marché des dispositifs
médicaux repose sur la confiance à
l'égard du fabricant et sur des
organismes certifiant peu encadré
généralement à but lucratif que le
fabricant choisit lui même selon ses
critères ce qui peut conduire un
nivellement par le bas
ce que vous nommez le forum shopping
enfin à aucun moment un regard
indépendant transparent scientifiquement
appropriée sur les bénéfices et les
risques du produit n'est portée par des
autorités compétentes
ces autorités n'interviennent finalement
qu'au moment du remboursement éventuel
mais alors avec les yeux du payeur et ce
n'est qu'une fois le produit sur le
marché que l'autorité exerce son rôle de
sécurité sanitaire et n'intervient le
plus souvent que lorsque l' alerte est
déjà lancé enfin pour ce qui a trait aux
actes et dispositifs à visée esthétique
il échappe la plupart du temps aux
procédures permettant de s'assurer
qu'ils répondent à des exigences de
sécurité sanitaire ce constat sévère ne
résume pas bien évidemment la richesse
de votre analyse votre travail vous a
conduit à établir 38 recommandations qui
pour chacune d'entre elles est le fruit
d'un imposant argumentaire il est
important de noter que ces
recommandations impose des actions à
plusieurs niveaux elle concerne à la
fois les dispositifs médicaux et les
actes à visée esthétique elle interpelle
aussi bien le niveau national que le
niveau européen
elle propose d'intervenir en amont de la
distribution des produits ou des actes
mais également de renforcer le contrôle
a posteriori c'est donc une palette
complète de mesures que vous proposez de
portée mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs depuis que la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé est en
poste
la question de la protection des
patients et de la sécurité des
procédures
et sa préoccupation constante vous devez
être assuré que sa détermination à
oeuvrer pour plus de qualité et donc
pour plus de sécurité est constante et
sans faille au plan national et je pense
que cela répondra aux constats liminaire
de madama archimbaud la totalité des
textes d'application de la loi du 29
décembre 2011 sont maintenant signer et
seront pour les derniers très
prochainement publié parmi ceux-ci
l'encadrement de la publicité des
dispositifs médicaux qui était très
attendu
les texte instaure un processus
d'autorisation préalable de la publicité
de certains de ces dispositifs notamment
les plus à risque
une autre disposition renforce la saisie
et le contrôle éventuellement de manière
inopinée par l' agence nationale de
sécurité des médicaments et des produits
de santé de certains dispositifs
remboursables la loi met également en
place
les déclarations d'intérêts et la
transparence des liens entre entreprises
et partenaires de la santé
son article 6 met à la charge des
entreprises produisant ou
commercialisant des produits de santé
dont les dispositifs médicaux
l'obligation de rendre publique
l'existence de conventions qu'elles
concluent avec tous les professionnels y
compris les étudiants exerçant dans les
domaines de la santé
ces entreprises sont également tenus de
rendre publics les avantages qu'elle
procure aux acteurs du champ des
produits de santé précités madame la
ministre a mis en place un groupe de
travail pour finaliser le décret sur la
publication des liens et des conventions
et ce décret devait devrait être porté
rapidement devant le conseil d'état pour
ce qui concerne les actes à visée
esthétique
la ministre s'est prononcé fermement le
23 mai dernier pour un durcissement de
la réglementation sur les cabines de
bronzage un décret dans ce sens est en
cours de finalisation
en effet la réglementation actuelle sur
ces appareils ne permet pas d'assurer la
meilleure protection
action pour tous vis-à-vis du risque de
cancer de la peau par exemple il
n'existe aucun dispositif réglementaire
permettant aux exploitants de cabines de
bronzage d' exiger du client qu'il
établisse la preuve de sa majorité
alors que l'on sait que 3,5 pour cent
des personnes âgées de 15 à 18 ans
déclarent avoir eu recours à des séances
de bronzage pour aller le cas échéant
plus loin encore si cela s'avérait
nécessaire
nous attendons les conclusions d'un avis
de la haute autorité de santé sur ce
sujet qui sera rendu courant 2013
sur le plan européen madame la ministre
souhaite que la france puisse peser de
tout son poids pour renforcer la
sécurité des usagers et assurer la
qualité tant des dispositifs que des
actes
madame la ministre a déjà rencontré le
commissaire dalli responsable de la
direction générale santé protection des
consommateurs
elle s'est entretenue entretenu par dont
récemment sur ce sujet avec ses
homologues de belgique d'allemagne
d'irlande du luxembourg de pologne afin
de peser sur les discussions en cours
en effet le débat est ouvert puisque un
projet de règlement européen sur les
dispositifs médicaux a été rendu public
la semaine dernière
ce projet corrige certaines déficiences
signalé précédemment
il conserve le dispositif de la
certification mais instaure un
renforcement et une harmonisation des
organismes notifiés et créer un groupe
de coordination formé d'experts des
autorités compétentes nationales il nous
paraît toutefois nécessaire d'aller plus
loin dans le mécanisme du contrôle
préalable par les autorités compétentes
nationales des dispositifs les plus à
risque
les procédures de déclaration des
données de sécurité mérite d'être encore
précisé en outre les procédures de
collaboration en matière d'inspection
doivent être renforcées au vu des
recommandations que vous formulez et de
notre propre analyse les propositions du
texte
présenté par la commission nous semble
encore insuffisante notamment pour
garantir la sécurité des dispositifs
médicaux les plus à risque enfin nous
pensons qu'il faut accélérer le partage
d'informations entre les autorités
compétentes pour qu'elles cuisent de
manière efficace accomplir leurs
missions de police sanitaire
effectivement la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans la qualité et la
sécurité de notre système de santé doit
être au rendez vous les trop nombreux
scandales qui se sont succédé ont entamé
cette confiance il nous faut la
reconstruire
les propositions que vous faites seront
étudiées soyez en assurés avec une
grande attention
vous le voyez certaines sont déjà en
cours
d'autres demandent un engagement
européen fort que nous porterons en
espérant emporter l'adhésion des autres
membres est un des deux autres étapes à
redon membres nous ne devons pas
élaborer un arsenal juridique dans la
précipitation après chaque scandale
nous souhaitons par contre que s'élabore
un dispositif solide
un dispositif qui prennent en compte les
risques réels auxquels les français
peuvent être soumis un dispositif qui
responsabilise chaque acteur autorités
publiques bien sûr mais également les
professionnels de santé les entreprises
produisant les dispositifs qu'ils soient
médicaux ou à visée esthétique
nous voulons que se mettre en place un
système performant de vigilance pour que
puisse être rapidement détecté un
dysfonctionnement et qu'il soit traité
avec célérité et efficacité
la ministre des affaires sociales et de
la santé est consciente du travail à
accomplir
le rapport que vous avez produit est
pour nous une aide précieuse car il nous
indique le chemin qu'il nous faut encore
parcourir
c'est par un travail conjoint que nous y
parviendrons
merci beaucoup
merci madame la ministre
voilà nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat
merci à vous d'avoir suivi ce débat
consacré aux conclusions de la mission
d'information du sénat sur les prothèses
et implants à visée médicale mais aussi
esthétique pour revoir cette séance
notre site internet publicsenat.fr très
belle journée à tous